The world's largest
volcano is erupting
for the first time in almost 40
Well,
as you can hear and see,
lava is flowing down
the side of the volcano.
The images
come out of the
mount of lower on Hawaii's Big I
Officials are telling
surrounding communities
that they are not in imminent da
as of now.
Let's bring in our chief
climate correspondent Mr. Bill W
Good morning to you.
So, 40 years and then this.
What is this is so thrilling.
I can't even tell you.
The volcanologists have been wai
This is one of the most measured
volcanoes in the world.
Volcanologist Volcanologists
been waiting for this event
for a long time.
They're studying it
intensely and native Hawaiians.
And I'll explain that in a secon
But this is not the kind of volc
that spews
big ash clouds
like we saw in Iceland or other
in the South Pacific.
It's the kind that sort of oozes
this mesmerizing lava.
There's fountains,
small and large,
popping that magma up there.
The Park Volcanoes
National Park is open
with some restrictions today.
So the people are lucky enough
to be there.
They're going to see this.
And here is why
native Hawaiians are so excited
Take a look at this.
I can not get there by Hawaii.
Bella, you know her momma.
Okay.
Luka is a native
Hawaiian practitioner and killer
The most active of the volcanoes
on the big island.
Like Bella, you know.
Hello?
Okay, Bella, you
And he carries on the belief
that this molten power
is evidence of the goddess Palan
even when she is
rearranging entire neighborhoods
with the kind of eruption that c
20. 18.
Pele is described with an affect
normally reserved
for temperamental relatives.
Imagine if the whole world
looked at their
their environment as their grand
or their father, that
they would treat them very diffe
Yeah.
And so that's how we try
and treat our environment
in that same way we look at them
As family
To a Hawaiian
volcanoes national park is as sa
as the Vatican.
To Catholics or Mecca to Muslims
We are headed to pay our homage
as we head towards the glow
on the horizon of the killer
whale volcano.
And it's for him and the line of
who are here
as people race
to get their best viewing spot
the see splatters of magma
and hopefully
a glimpse into the lava lake
that's from The Wonder List
now streaming on Discovery.
Plus, by the way.
But it's so cool that the touris
will actually get to experience
the double eruption right now,
by the way.
For clarification,
you said a big ash with an s h c
right, instead.
Well, it goes both ways.
It goes both ways.
This is a big ash cloud.
You saw
we saw
and what you just showed,
you said rearranging neighborhoo
So how do they know volcanologis
How do officials know that
this is a threat?
They can measure
sort of the seismic activity,
the number of volcano or earthqu
doubled in since September.
So they know something's coming,
but they still don't know precis
when it will pop.
Right now, the love is flowing n
Most of the communities
are to the south that can shift.
But the biggest concern really i
is what's in the air,
the gases that come off.
And Pele's hair,
that's these
thin strands of glass
that if you breathe them
can be really dangerous.
But right now,
it looks like nobody's in any da
Fascinating.